lava pouring forth from the world's  largest active volcano  for the first time in 38 years Mauna Loa  Hawaiian for Long Mountain is awake  the huge volcano on Hawaii's big island  is once again throwing forth streams of  lava and Ash  while it's spewing sulfur dioxide and  other volcanic gases into the air  authorities say the Island's roughly 200  000 residents aren't in immediate Danger  from lava  lava flows are not threatening any  downslope communities at this time and  all the indications are that the  eruption will remain in the Northeast  drift Zone  volcanic gas and possibly fine Ash and  pele's hair may be carried downwind  people are being urged to be prepared to  move quickly  during a 1950 eruption lava traveled  some 24 kilometers in just three hours  but for now some are content to stand  back  and witness as a sleeping giant wakes up